you're broadly supportive of uh
President Putin's actions in Ukraine so
tell us what you expect President Putin
to outline later on today
good morning thank you for giving me
your floor but I don't know exactly what
Buddhism is going to say but I know that
there's going to be juridical procedure
for those territories from Ukraine to
join Russia uh putting should sign a
treaty between the foreign
then we should pass this treaty on
Council of federation and only after
that Putin will sign it and uh
officially uh those territories will be
the part we will be part of Russia uh I
we are expecting that Putin will give us
a huge statement on uh
current situation on what we should do
next after the Parisian donbass will
join Russia because we should
continue to
defend the people on donbass we should
see it around the table with you with
the west and we should agree on
safety guarantees for Russian people for
don't bus people
but the UN Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez said last night that any
decision to proceed with the annexation
of these areas would have no legal value
and deserves to be condemned Russia's a
permanent member of the U.N security
Council so shouldn't it take notice of
that warning that this move would be
illegal
oh Anna uh please don't live in a
western meets because what can you say
me about Marvin's Islands about Holland
Heights what what can you say me about
what uh your forces
did in Iraq and Afghanistan and uh
uh would you tell me how the vast had
divided a huge country of Yugoslavia 20
years ago uh it's it's illegal for us
it's illegal for people in donbass we
should defend them you should understand
it because they live on the Ukrainian
shelling for the last eight years and
Don Bosque have lost uh around 14
000 people in this war for the last
eight years not from February and Russia
must defend people on their status rates
that's it it's illegal for Russia it's
legal for millions of people in uh you
know former Ukrainian territories you
say it's legal for Russia but President
Putin has used these so-called
referendums as a pretext for this
annexation and there's no International
recognition of these votes is that the
process wasn't meant monitored
independently it's been widely condemned
by Ukraine and countries around the
world as a sham
okay
and what what should you do next what
can you do with us I have heard the the
news from you uh from Britain about high
prices High tariffs electricity problems
and gas problems uh you gonna uh fill
those problems you're gonna feel your
sanctions your sanctions we didn't
sanction uh uh uh the Western countries
but you now struggling those sanctions
you're gonna pay high prices for
sanctions against Russia we gonna
develop our country we're gonna develop
um a new territories and we gonna
protect people on donbas and the parisia
and persona
and President Putin has said he's
prepared to use nuclear weapons if
Russia's a territorial Integrity is
threatened is all that's happening at
the moment partly a sign that President
Putin is worried he's losing public
support at home at the moment isn't he
because of these uh partial mobilization
of reservists
uh well Anna uh you should uh carefully
listen uh for Putin's statements we're
not threatening to anybody with our
nuclear weapon we just tell you that we
have nuclear weapon I'm sure that we're
not gonna use it first
it's not our Like rules uh we have
Doctrine about using nuclear weapon and
we're gonna use it only in response if
you or any other Western Country
should gonna attack us with nuclear
weapon of course we will respond but
using nuclear weapon in 21st century
it's an and same decision we are not
insane and we hope that you too
Afghani pop-off have we lost you
uh oh your line just broke up the the
signal came and went on the end of your
answer there but just very quickly we
haven't got very much time but very
briefly just on this question of the
partial mobilization of reservists
President Putin yesterday acknowledged
that mistakes had been made calling up
people who didn't have military
experience or qualified for exemption is
he concerned about this call up that has
seen so many men heading for the borders
trying to get out of Russia
well Anna yes you are seeing just a
picture of what you want to see yes some
people are fleeing Russia but much more
people uh hundreds 000 people are joined
Army right now many of them by volunteer
and they gonna protect our country
we have some concerns about this
partially mobilization but we don't have
an experience of mobilization for
decades we gonna fix those mistakes I do
uh fixed
many mistakes as a deputy as a member of
Parliament and my colleague is going to
do it and uh doing it now uh that's okay
everything is okay if this partial
mobilization we know that our people are
ready to defend our country